you know i want to take a moment it's
kind of i don't want i want to say it's
a moment of silence but we're not going
to be silent because honestly moment of
silences are [ __ ] really who the
guy's dead you know what i'm talking
about hey when i'm dead
no moments of silence all right
and don't be one of those [ __ ] [ __ ]
asses who posts me and [ __ ] especially
if like you stab me in the back of my
hard times
don't be like a [ __ ] ass and [ __ ] be
like oh dude
you know
we all have our [ __ ] but boy crystalia
he sure shook the room with laughter god
[ __ ] eat my dick dude don't post me
in black and white i don't want none of
that [ __ ]
i won't be i won't be around who's it
for
moment of silence for the fallen for
what they're dead
so uh no moments of silence
but uh we respect the [ __ ] out of vin
scully because uh he was great he was
like the last baseball announcer that
was just him he didn't even have another
guy
that's so gangster the guy's 150 and he
would just [ __ ] straight up talk to
himself they don't even do that anymore
and the dodgers he was just like not
till i die will there be two announcers
but right before he died he just goes
syed retired
he just goes bro he just goes
brought to you by
[Laughter]
brought to you by
death
brought to you by
the grim reaper
brought to you by
my last breath
dude he's straight up [ __ ] pissed out
vin scully was my favorite dude so shout
out to that [ __ ] keeping it real
remember when he did that crazy tweet
about his eye what was inside his eye
that was absolutely disgusting but dude
the guy was a legend man
the inside of my eye
has something in it let me tweet it
long fly ball deep to center
i think it's a stye in my eye and he's
out
but uh yeah dude
vin scully was the man dude
and he never stopped announcing dude he
was unreal he would just talk and talk
and talk and talk and talk and do to
other
teams like the astros and the phillies
they bitched out and had two dudes they
had the regular announcer and then the
color announcer you know no not a racist
thing that's what they call them and um
vince scully was just like i'll handle
it all myself
he would just be like todd zale steps up
to the plate
he's
oh and two so far in this game it's the
sixth inning quick game that's been
happening
we're at just about an hour and 20
minutes
zeal from a small town in ohio
with lineage and roots that grow into
kentucky swinging a miss strike one
stepping out of the batter's box
zeal takes a look over to his there's
been trouble in the dugout ever since
the beginning of the cardinals game
the relief pitcher
and you're just like
you just drones on and on
birds keep flying into the dugout and
the manager swats him away
swinging a miss strike too
long fly ball deep to enter deep to
center
just took a picture of my eye and he's
out
[Laughter]
hensley mulens catches it and rockets it
back to third base the runner goes back
doc what do you think it is that's wrong
with my eye
safe
shout out to [ __ ] v vin scully don't
need no one dude he was gangster as [ __ ]
i don't need anyone
just me
that is some real that is a real
[ __ ]
i work alone i'm basically th
the batman of announcers
i don't want any help
of course they're
commit of course i understand
occasionally commissioner gordon will
call on me he but
scully's basically batman dude
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] there goes the riddler with the
jewels we'll see what he sends us in the
mail
what smiles but doesn't smile and
[Laughter]
what brings april flowers but may
showers
all right wow i mean i'm so [ __ ]
goddamn annoying rest in peace to vin
scully the batman of announcer didn't
need nobody dude
didn't need [ __ ] nobody here's a tick
tock of him i guess one fire just sent
it to me ah vin scully's final sign off
here we go
here we
go here we go come on coming
oh wow
oh wow
many years ago
a little red-headed boy was walking home
from school passing a chinese laundry
and stopped to see the score of a world
series game what a legend in the window
the yankees beat the giants 18-4 on
october the 2nd 1936.
well the boy's reaction was pity for the
giants and he became a rabid giants fan
from that day forward until the joyous
moment when he was hired to broadcast
brooklyn dodger
when he was i hired to broadcast
brooklyn dodger games
i work alone
um
damn dude
what a trip that brings me back god dude
nostalgia is crazy i mean i have vid i
have game i have
images of game my [ __ ] uncles man my
uncle richard my uncle vinnie and my dad
and my brother they all watch the mets
games they love the mets and dude my
uncle vinnie is so [ __ ] superstitious
he won't pee
when the mets
he won't go to the bathroom when the
mets are
uh
not
at bat
he thinks if he goes to the he's never
done it
it's not like a cute thing he like
genuinely has never gone to the bathroom
when the mets
are in the field because he
that's when they lose
you know
like
i have uh what do you call it ocd and
then sometimes i have to stop and i
think wait a minute this is so
egotistical to think that
me pissing out my peen
has to do
with anything then
in the world period
i should tell my uncle vinnie that
i don't know man but we missed vince
scully dude that guy was this [ __ ] crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
[Music]